[NO SPEECH]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DINESH KULKARNI: Welcome
to Google Chrome Next 2017.
Welcome to the
first session, I'm
glad you're all
enthused and interested.
It was good and bad both
to see the line outside.
Good because of
the interest and we
have lots of interesting
things to cover.
And bad because I
wish all of those guys
could sit inside, because we
are beginning the session.
So if you can have
folks from outside,
there's plenty of room,
I can see empty chairs
all over the back.
That would be
great to let people
in from the stand by line.
My name is Dinesh
Kulkarni, and I'm
a product manager in the
cloud team at Google,
and I work on two products.
One is data lab,
and the other one
is cloud machine
learning engine.
Both were announced for
GA earlier in the keynote.
My co-speakers are J.J.
Allaire, founder, entrepreneur,
and CEO of our studio.
For those in the group
that do art, and love art
we love art too and he's going
to show some interesting demos
later.
And then I have Hongfei and
a few members of his team
from KPMG, who've been
working with us to show
a great financial services app.
So a shoutout for both of
them, J.J. From our studio
and Hongfei from KPMG.
Another quick thing,
I figured out here
it's International Women's Day.
Tribute to all the
women who've contributed
to these products in software
engineering, and other roles.
And a special
welcome to the women
in the crowd on this
International Women's Day.
So let's get back
to our session.
So here is the tone for
machine learning at Google,
is set by our former CEO and
current chairman Eric Schmidt.
The way he describe
was interesting,
think of the earlier
generation of programming
as telling machines what
they should do meticulously.
And now we're
doing a transition,
and we're in the early
part of the transition.
From that imperative, here's
what the computer does,
I'll feed you data, I'll
get you started with models,
you figure out what
the user wants,
you figured out if
there is a fraud,
you figured out what
the image means.
And that is the kind of
interesting transition
that we're doing.
We've been going
through this transition
internally for over a decade.
And what this stock
tries to capture
is the confluence of what
the cloud products do,
and the learnings from those
projects over the last 12 years
or so that combined from a
coherent machine learning
lifecycle.
As in case of
software development
it's not just
about writing code,
here it's not just about
finding the right algorithm
and creating a model.
It is all about the entire
lifecycle end to end.
And just as there is this SDLC
software development lifecycle
that walks you through
requirements all the way to how
to make sure that you have
the right system deployed.
Similarly in machine
learning, we're
going to take a quick look
at the entire lifecycle
and that's the main
topic of this talk.
So here is the problem that
we're going to start with.
I want to get an operational ML
model for some business problem
that I have, and it could be
in any of multiple domains.
But before we start
on that, let's
have a quick show
of hands so that I
have a sense of where people
are at and what they have done.
How many in the
audience have not
deployed a working machine
learning system so far?
OK that seems like the
majority that's fine,
we'll covered what it involves.
How many of you have not
used Tensorflow before?
That's a majority
as well, don't worry
I'm not going to go into a
deep Tensorflow competitional
graphs and optimizations.
There's a machine learning
without a PhD talk that
does that, we'll
covered the basics
and we'll start a reasonably
sort of high level of algorithm
specification.
How many in the
audience do Python?
Looks like close to
majority but not quite.
How many do R?
OK that's a sizable number I
don't know what the rest do
but if you're going to do
indie Python and R code here.
I'm sorry.
Apologies in advance
if you do Matlab,
or SaaS or some other thing.
I don't have demos for that.
But we'll cover Python
and Ar for sure.
All right.
So with that let's
get to the lifecycle.
The first step is to find
the business problem.
Then a bunch of things
related to data,
in fact machine
learning is really
not a statistical
machine learning
problem it is fundamentally
a big data problem.
And tack onto that some advanced
machine learning algorithms
and engines and you've got
a good sort of progress
that you can make.
You need to collect data
first, from various sources
logs, systems of record,
the transactional data.
It might be some
external purchased data
like maps related, zip code,
demographic information,
whatever.
You would bring that together
in a data preparation step.
Make sure that it's
all brought together,
so that you can
use it from machine
learning in a coherent single
sort of feature set form.
And then you would
analyze that often
to do feature engineering.
To figure out which
of the myriad columns
or which of the myriad features
are relevant for building
the right kind of model.
And then you would honestly
step into the modeling part,
train a model,
evaluate the model
to make sure it meets
your requirements
or meets your error bar.
And then optimize it to get
the last ounce of performance
that you can get
out of the model.
And then the fun part starts.
In fact when you're done
with model think of it
that you're done with maybe 60%,
70%, you've got at least 30%,
40% remaining.
But you would take the
model and deploy that.
Maybe deploy multiple models,
experiment with them and it
could be composite sense.
Collect the data.
And then manage the
lifecycle of the models,
including rolling back.
And we've got a set of products
that target different things.
BigQuery, Dataflow, and
Dataproc are the products
that deal with big data.
BigQuery does about SQL on up
to terabytes of data in a snap.
Maybe by bringing together
thousands or Tens of thousands
of machines to run in query.
Dataflow is hard on
streaming and batch data.
And Ddataproc is our hosted
version of Spark and Hadoop.
And then the product
that went GA today,
machine learning engine,
cloud machine learning engine.
And that product deals with
models, how to train them,
evaluate, optimize, and so on.
And then Datalab provides Python
based experience, notebook
based experience,
for going through all
these different steps.
And of course our studio,
the latest addition
that will allow you to do
similar things in AR as well.
And then rounding out is
a set of services provided
by Google and by
partners like KPMG that
help you go through these.
A slight segue here
I want to cover,
the machine learning
products are very briefly so
that we are clear on what we are
covering in the remaining talk
and what not.
There is a set of
APIs that are mainly
meant for software developers.
As in you don't have to
worry about creating model,
you don't even have to
worry about training data.
We have data, we have models
all you do is make an API call,
or thousands of them
second, and we'll return
whatever information you need.
For example speech to text, or
finding objects in an image,
or the recent edition of
video intelligence where
it finds entities in a given
video at different points
in the timeline.
And then that is
machine learning engine
where we don't give you data,
we don't give you a model,
it's your data,
your model, we make
sure that we can run it at
scale for you, for training
and for prediction.
So effectively it's
a way of taking
care of the systems aspect
of the machine learning part.
So we're going to
talk exclusively
about machine
learning, I'm not going
to cover the app development
using API's, there
are separate talks for that.
This is all about
machine learning
models and their lifecycle,
and for the life cycle
they have to be born so
we'll go through that.
The cloud machine
learning engine
itself is based on Tensorflow,
an open source project that's
been getting a lot of attention
and we are gratified by that.
A lot of research
interest, a lot of product
interest as well
from third parties.
So you can think of it as
the machine learning engine
sitting on top of TensorFlow
and providing scalable managed
service.
It also connects
with other services,
and we'll see examples
of BigQuery and Dataflow.
And as of today we have
GPU's available in beta so
you can run your
training much faster.
The life cycle support the rest
of the talk will covered that.
And then it's completely
open, the principle
behind cloud machine
learning engine
is you can take your
model, is your model
you can take it out
anytime you want
or you can bring it
anytime you want.
So for example there are
companies that do training
at scale on machine
learning engine,
but then they take that model
and they run it on premise
or wherever they are running
their production system.
And that's fine too,
that's an available option.
You can do the reverse
as well, bring in a model
and you want to take
care of prediction
we'll do that as well.
And so there's a
set of products that
support that we're going to
go through all the details.
So let's get back
to the lifecycle,
for this lifecycle the
best way to think about it
is in an iterative fashion.
Same life cycle of splitted sort
of into the data versus model
versus the deployed
system aspects.
You can think of
it as a waterfall,
just for simplicity
but in reality
it will never be a waterfall.
Whenever you're preparing
data and analyzing
you might discover that you
just don't have enough data.
In fact we'll see
the census demo
where the data isn't
all that great,
and that's sort of
the point that you
have to go back get more data.
Then when you're doing
modeling it's the same.
Usually you would start with
the simplest algorithm possible,
maybe in a linear regression
for structured data.
There are a few rules of thumb
you would follow and just use
those.
But then when you find that
your model quality isn't
exactly what you want,
you would go back
make changes and train again.
After you're done with that to
get additional performance out
of it you might do
hyperparameter optimization.
Like number of learns in a
neural network, learning rate,
and those kinds of parameters.
You might queue them
and get a better model.
Even in the deployment
management sense,
you'd be running experiments
and if your new model doesn't
perform in production,
no matter how well it
does in your notebook or in
your data science platform,
you'll pull back and
revert to the old one,
or you might turn multiple
ones and pick the right one.
And not only that, you might
go back based on an experiment
and say, hey, user
behavior has changed.
Maybe a new app
has launched, users
don't do what they used to
do 3 months ago or a week ago
in fact.
And I'm going to
collect more data
and figure out how to
improve my predictions.
For the demos we're going to
focus on the blue box here,
that covers from analysis
to very basic deployment.
And we will not go into the
problem definition and so on.
But because of that, I just
give it one slide, it's new.
This is actually the
most important part
of the lifecycle.
As they say "If you don't
know where you're going,
any road will take you there."
So this is the one about
knowing where you're
going, if you have crisp
business objectives,
and I've listed three
at the top that happened
to be the ones that we're
going to go to in the demo,
that very sort of demo
centric quick ones.
And then I've
listed another five
that are actual industry
problems that have
been stalled using CloudML.
I'll only briefly
allude to those.
Identifying clouds
in satellite imagery.
This was mentioned
earlier I think
it can be mentioned in
all other talk in detail.
Identifying damaged boxes on
a conveyor belt for a retailer
to avoid bad boxes
going through and then
causing downstream problems.
Finding additional
products to recommend
users, the typical
recommendation problem.
For financial service
detecting anomalies to find out
fraud or noncompliance.
And then for customer
support kinds of cases,
identifying the sentiment
and customer feedback.
So if somebody is
really angry you
can route them to a
human representative
and not try to automate every
part of the interaction.
All right, so the second part,
which again you know briefly
as Andrew Ang in
his class mentions,
"Data is the rocket
fuel, no matter
how good your rocket is,
if you don't have fuel
it's not going to take off."
So that's what you should
concentrate, obviously
for these demos we
already have the data
that we wanted, so
we won't be going
to the concept of how
do we go and find data,
aggregated together and so on.
But really critical parts.
All right so with that
let's switch to demo.
All right how many of you
are familiar in the audience
with Jupiter notebooks,
or right Python notebooks?
I see about 60%
or so that means,
don't worry if
you're not, im going
to go through a quick
Hello World tour.
So the product that
I'm showing here
is our Datalab,
Google cloud Datalab.
This is a hosted Jupiter
based data science tool,
and it is meant for
Python developers.
Art studio will recover later.
So let's take the
simplest notebook.
One of the notebooks
that's available,
and this is all in the GA
product that's available today.
Is there's a simple untitled
Hello World notebook.
And this Hello World notebook
lets you Doodle around.
There's a slight difference
between using an ID or a code
editor and using an notebook.
We'll see that.
So I have code here that just
does the mandatory Hello World,
because you have to start any
basic thing with print Hello,
or Hello World.
So I just ran it, I
can go to the sale,
I can run it with that
or do shift-enter, which
keyboard based people prefer.
And I can run this.
Now, the interesting thing
is that I have some markdown
documentation here
like comments,
but it renders better in this
form, so I can just change it.
I can run the code.
So that this code and
these are the results
I can type new code here.
I'm going to show you
a plot, because it's
boring to just look at text.
And we'll do that.
What I'm going to do is plot
two arrays of a typical xy plot,
just to give you a
sense of what it does.
I'm going to pass in two arrays.
The first one is just
numbers, and then
the squares of those numbers.
16 comma 25, so as
you can see, it's
going to be just a normal
parabola once I'm done.
Let's specify the axes,
again, in an array.
Now this Matplotlib
is a external library
that is commonly used in the
Jupyter or Python data science
world.
We've got packaged
a set of libraries
for data visualization
for analysis NumPy
and so on, SciPy
within Datalab, so you
don't have to go looking
for those, or install those.
They're just available.
Let's specify the axes as 0
to 6 on the x-axis, and 0 to,
let's say, 30 because
that's within the squares.
And then, I'll do a pl dot
show, which will show the plot.
OK, so as I would expect,
I've got a half parabola here.
I can do all these interesting
things, visualize the data,
write code, have documentation.
And then, it becomes
not just something
that I have for referring
back, so that when
I do analysis of data
and I want to go back,
I have all those steps and
results right in front of me.
It also becomes an artifact
that I can share with my team
members very easily.
And then, they can just
go to and say, ah, OK,
what you were doing was this.
I get what you're doing.
So for example here, I could
have just added up a cell here,
and done some more
work, or provided
some additional
documentation, and so on.
So that's notebook
in a nutshell.
So let's get to our data science
now, and machine learning.
The problem that we want
to solve using these tools
is fairly straightforward.
The census data collects
demographic information,
like age, gender, and education
level, and for some surveys,
it collects fairly detailed
data, anonymized of course.
And that provides the
income information
about whoever was surveyed.
And this anonymized data
is available publicly.
We're going to take that data,
and see if we can build a model
to predict income.
So effectively take
the column the problem
that we have in data, make
it the target for prediction,
build a model, and see if
you can predict the income,
and then figure out
how good our model is.
OK, so let's run these,
clear all the cells.
Clearing all the
cells will remove
all the existing
previous executions,
so I start from scratch.
First one, I set
up the workspace,
just importing a set of
libraries that I want,
all packaged in Datalab that
you can just directly use.
I can set up my
workspace path, create
the appropriate directory,
remove all the things
that I don't want,
look at my CSV file,
and we'll get to that in a
second, what it contains.
So just copy over data
from a central site,
for my local analysis to my VM.
This is all running in GCE--
in Google Compute Engine--
in a VM.
I've got the files copied,
so I've got my data.
Now, the next part
is interesting
because I'm going
to actually look
at what my data looks like.
OK, so as you can see, this is
all sort of numbers and opaque
things.
That is deliberate.
It's all anonymized by
the Census Department, US
Government Commerce Department.
And that's the form
that it is available in.
I can see the serial number.
I can see what these
different things are,
and then, finally, I
can see the income,
if I scroll all
the way to the end.
The next step is going
to be cleaning this data
and transforming.
One of the challenges is
that-- and this is sometimes
impolitely called data
janitor's job, because really it
is pretty unclean, because
there are unknown values that
are missing values that
are flat out wrong values.
And so you have to
go to a lot of work
in order to make sure
that your data is clean.
There's another product called
Google Cloud Data Preparation--
I won't go into that-- that
lets you do graphically.
But here we'll do it
the data scientist
preferred way, which is
looking at it, and saying,
hey, what do I do
with each of these?
Now, I want go to the
exact details of it,
but what I'm doing here is
finding interesting columns.
How did I arrive at that?
You know, I do care
about the address.
I do care about the
education level.
But I don't care about
some other details,
right, like wherever,
how long they've
lived at that
place or something,
may not be interesting.
It may be or may not.
In this case, it is not.
And so, instead,
what I'm going to do
is create a data frame that
transforms the data by taking
care of the columns that I
want, getting rid of the ones
that I don't want.
And another thing
that is interesting
is I'm not expecting this
model to predict down
to the penny what
are the earnings.
I'm just interested in
thousands, multiple.
We're talking about somebody
making 55,000 or 65,000 here.
That's the interesting part.
OK, so we've run this one.
Let's see what the
data looks like.
I've got a subset of the data.
Now there are no unknown values
or anything left on this one,
so I'll create the data set.
I've got data ready for my
machine learning workflow.
The next common step is
to take the entire corpus
of data you have.
Typically, you would
take a sample out of that
so that you can work
with it very quickly.
Obviously, if you have
terabytes of data,
even with all the scale, it's
going to take several minutes.
And in the print, you know,
eval, edit, and print loop,
you want it to be as
quick as you can make it.
So you'll probably
start with a sample,
just to get on the right path.
With that sample, you'll
again split it into two.
You want data that is held back
for testing the model that you
have, and then
data that is going
to be used for actually training
and validation within the train
relative loop.
So that's what we
are doing here.
We're going to create training
and evaluation data sets.
And that split is based on
80:20 partitions, and random.
Again, I won't go
through the details
of how you would look at
the characteristics of both
to make sure they're
statistically sufficiently
similar, so that your
test is actually valid.
So let's go to a little more
of creation of the data sets,
and just making sure that
they have the right schema,
and then let's see
what files we have.
OK, so I have census,
eval, and train.
So this entire census
is sampled, and then
that sampled one is split
into train and eval.
So that's my two
sets of data sets.
Now, I can use those
as train and eval data,
all happening in
memory on the VM.
And then, I can
analyze this data
to understand what
analysis-- what
are the common
characteristics of this data.
So when you're
training your model,
you would typically want your
data in a canonical format.
So there are numerical columns.
You would turn those
into scaled ones.
You might have values, for
example, your income, that
might go from zero to
1 million or something,
and you will want to bring
them down to minus 1 to 1.
Or if you have categorical
columns, like gender,
or you might have a categorical
column for the zip code,
you want to do the appropriate
encoding, because, you know,
99033--
which happens to be the
zip code of my office--
that doesn't mean anything,
as opposed to 99007.
You want them encoded, so that
there are distinct values,
discrete values, and so on.
So that is the kind of analysis
and transformation work
that needs to be
done on that data,
before it is ready to be
fed into whatever engine,
whether it's TensorFlow
or some other agent
that you're using for training.
So that's what we're doing here.
So first part is
analysis, min/max values,
so if you know how to
scale it to minus 1 to 1.
So it's fairly simple here,
because structured data,
you don't have images
in this example.
But we've scaled that.
Let's see what my
analysis part looks like.
I've got vocabulary.
So for the distinct values, what
I want is I want vocabularies.
So if it's gender, my vocabulary
is to a male and female,
or that's what at least the
US census data contains.
If it's zip codes, I'll
have some, many thousands
of zip codes in my vocabulary.
So those are the
vocabulary files that
are going to get used later.
Because, remember, you can have
those opaque constants where
you want to get back for
validation and for testing
the values you had to
see if your data matches
what the model predicted.
So these are the vocabularies
that cover the analysis
and transformation part.
Now comes the key
part of training.
This is usually the
most exciting part,
because, you know, it's
like watching water boil.
The network or whatever
else is training with it,
but somehow this is something
the data scientists love,
so we'll go through that.
These are the sets of features
that we've identified.
I won't go through
how we've identified.
You would look at
correlations, remove the ones
that are mostly duplicative.
If there's no correlation
between target
and a particular column,
you would eliminate it.
But these are sets
of columns that
cover that particular part.
So this is what
we're going to use.
This is the feature
set we've defined.
Using this feature set,
now comes the training,
real training part.
Now TensorFlow is a very
rich and sometimes complex
computational graph
computation system.
So if you're building
the graph from scratch
using individual operations,
like, I want to do a log,
I want to do some
other transformation,
then it's great for that level.
But there are higher
level APIs that you
can use, like the
estimators, or what
are used to be called
TFLearn, or you can use Keras,
or you can use
higher level tools
kits like the Datalab
tool kit here,
which provides even
simpler capabilities.
So if you have structured
data, here you can just say,
regression.train.
I want a regression model.
So from the toolbox I pick
up my regression tool.
And I say, hey, regression
tool, I want to do training.
Here's my data.
So here is my train data.
Remember the split we did?
That's this one.
Here's my eval data, et cetera.
Now, all of this is going
to happen locally, actually.
For quick iterations,
we've provided libraries
that effectively mimic
what Cloud ML does
at scale on thousands of
machines and GPUs locally.
This is going to happen
on a GCM, single VM.
I've taken sample data so
I can do it very quickly.
Let's run this one.
What is happening here, is the
metric called regression.dot
train, is very, very similar
to what you would do in cloud.
You will extract-- provide
extra configuration information
when you're ready
to run the training
against the full set of data.
So for example, there's a
Kaggle challenge called Criteo.
The data is 1 terabytes.
You would not try to even
load that one terabyte of data
in a VM and run it,
or any single machine,
even if it's a big honking, 32
CPU, whatever, 128 gig machine.
You would probably sample
it down to a gig or so.
You would take
that, train locally.
Once the training
is done locally,
you would take, essentially,
the full of terabyte data,
apply similar sets of
steps, except at scale.
So when you run the
data flow, here it
runs it locally
to do the analysis
that I showed you, computing
the range, min, max, and so on.
All that is happening locally.
You would take that, and
say, hey, data flow service,
go and run it for me.
And they might spin
up 1,000 machines,
and run it, come back in six
minutes instead of coming back
in six hours.
But it's still six minutes.
You probably want to
do all the work here,
so now the training is finished.
As the training was happening,
it printed out information
about the global steps, the
loss, how it was converging,
the loss keeps going down.
Sometimes, it goes up, but
overall it keeps going down.
So it starts somewhere
in the 1956 range,
and then, if you go down
here, the loss is 227,
and the training is completed.
I can see this on
TensorBoard as well.
And then, I can see it
within Datalab lab, as well.
So here I can see the global.
Let's look at a few things.
So this is my deep neural
network the, hidden layers
and so on.
I won't go through each
and every detail of this.
There is a separate talk that
goes into just these details.
But I can see,
basically, my graphs.
I can see how my
loss is performing.
Remember we were looking
at the loss coming down.
That is sort of the training
loss that's coming down.
All right, so let's get
back to our notebook.
I can also stop my
TensorBoard, so I can--
I don't need to keep running.
I can look at the train
model, where it is.
The reason why
this is important,
why I'm showing
you the model, is
to emphasize the fact
that it is your model.
You can take it out.
Take it to wherever you want,
on premise, some other cloud.
And you can run predictions,
if you so choose.
Obviously, we hope you would
run predictions on our cloud.
And we've made arrangements to
provide predictions at scale,
but in the end, it's
your model, your choice.
You can bring it in
anytime you want,
take it out anytime you want.
It's all here.
It's local.
It will be in the cloud storage
when you run it at scale.
OK, so the next
step is evaluation.
We've got a train model.
We held back 20%
of data, saying I
want to test it, and see
if our model is any good.
So let's do that.
For evaluation,
essentially, what it's doing
is batch prediction.
In batch prediction, you say,
I have this set of records.
I have the model.
Please host the model.
Run this data, batch
data, through it,
and give me a set
of predictions.
So in this case, it's a
set of individual records
for different people that
were held back, anonymized.
And then, I'm going to look at
the income that's predicted,
compare it with the income that
I had in the test data set,
because it's a known value.
Effectively, it's
batched prediction,
followed by a
comparison of the target
value and the predicted value.
So I'm effectively showing you
batch prediction, as well Batch
prediction is no different.
You skip the evaluation
part of comparing results,
because you don't know
what the result is.
For example, when you're
recommending something
to a user, you don't know
if they'll actually like it
or not.
Whereas in the training
data, you'll see,
yeah, they liked it, they
clicked on it, they bought it.
OK, so batch prediction
is completed.
We get this path.
We will evaluate that, and
see what the predicted is,
the target is predicted.
Some are close, some are not--
65, 58, not bad,
62 29, not good.
We have limited data.
So remember, that
is not necessarily
the root mean square error
standard measures of how
good the model is.
You can compute all of that.
And I can look at
the distribution,
where is the error most.
Now, obviously, I want this
to be lowest, closer to zero.
I want all samples here.
But I can see the left side
tail and the right side tail.
So I can either analyze lots
of things in the same format.
It's not about firing up
your Python code editor,
writing code, then having
another thing to plot in.
It's all within the same
Datalab environment.
OK, and then, I
can do prediction.
The prediction here is
like online prediction.
I want to do spot checks.
I'm not trying to do a
deployment in production here,
I'm just trying to figure out
how this is going to work.
So I have some instances.
These are a few
instances I'm going
to run predictions against,
and then, run that, OK.
Whoops, I picked the
wrong one, before I try.
So these are the ones.
OK.
I have hosted the
model for us to model.
They do essentially the
same thing All right,
so let's go back, and quickly
look at the cloud one.
I can show you
the service train.
Here, if I go back
to my index here,
I can go and look at
the training part.
So for training, I had
this regression.train,
and this was the API call.
When I tried to do it at scale,
I have very similar API call.
It's the same, regression.train.
And the only difference here
is, I have cloud=config,
and I provided some config
about how many workers I want,
what I want to do, and so on.
So it's very symmetric.
You can do the lifecycle
locally, and then
take it remote.
All right, so with that,
let's get back to this.
The next one is going to
be a major identification,
classifying bolts, boring bolts
like these, industrial bolts.
Think of it as an image
recognition problem,
and you're going to use
a new technique called
transfer learning.
These are the bolts, 11 bolts,
that my colleague, [INAUDIBLE]
trained the model on.
They found all these
interesting bolts,
and now the machine
learning model
is required to learn about that.
All right, so, let's
switch to demo again.
All right.
OK, so this is the
bolts training.
I won't go through all of this.
What I'll do instead, is I'll
show you the most interesting
parts here.
So let's look at
the data briefly.
Set it up, so I
can view the data.
I can make the worker directory.
I won't do the pre-processing,
that takes some time.
What I'll do instead,
is zoom in on this.
OK, so this is, sort of a
deliberately somewhat opaque
of a graph.
This is the neural network.
The entire neural
network for inception
is trained on hundreds
of millions of images.
Often you don't have
enough data of that kind.
For example, with
the 11 bolts, I'm
not going to get into
millions of images,
and I may not get a quality
model without enough data.
Here what are we going to
do is use inception model
that can recognize,
I don't know, a desk,
or a panda, or a
fish, or a building.
Take that model,
teach that model
the incremental
additional thing,
just as you would
when you learned
second, third, fourth language,
you don't learn from scratch.
You already know
what you've learned.
Similarly, this
large inception model
that has been trained on
hundreds of millions of images
is the baseline.
On that, when applied training
for various bolt images,
these kinds of bolts, their
images, and then train it.
Somewhere [INAUDIBLE]
on this one.
It's going to run
local training,
and it's going to produce,
effectively, an incrementally,
or transferred,
learned train model.
Again, the loss keep going down.
The advantage of
this is twofold.
One is you may not have
data, as I mentioned.
The second advantage
is, if you were training
that kind of a model,
you're looking at weeks
worth of training time.
That's a very long,
and would be very
expensive to keep
training it on thousands
of machines for a week.
All that work has been done.
That model is available.
You can just add your data.
In fact, later,
there's a code lab
downstairs, on the
first floor by the end.
You'll do something
more beautiful
than these boring old bolts.
You can do sunflowers
and nice flower images,
but I figured you guys might
like boring stuff better
like bolts, because this is
closer to industrial things
than beautiful flower.
Plus, I wasn't sure if I could
bring all the flowers here.
So let's do this.
We won't, this time, go and
look at that TensorFlow one.
It'll show the model and so on.
Instead, what we do is
we'll look at the events.
The events are logged
as the training happens.
Based on these events, I can
get the loss and accuracy curves
here, so I can see how
my model is converging.
It's converging nicely.
The loss is coming down.
This is fantastic.
And then, I can take
this and predict, which
is the most interesting part.
So let's run prediction.
And what it's doing, it's
just taking these two images,
the hook image, and other
thing called if he bought it.
So this is the HFE bolt
and this one is the hook.
It's taking those images,
previously captured.
They were held back
for just spot checking.
And so it shows the hook.
It preducts it correctly,
takes the HFE bolt,
and predicts it correctly.
OK, so once it does that,
I can go into BigQuery,
put this data, this
perfect place to analyze.
I can create the evaluation set.
Instead of just looking,
doing spot check,
now I'm doing proper testing.
So it's doing the prediction.
And once it's predicted, then
I can look how it's behaving.
So while it's doing the
prediction on whatever data
that I held back, let's go and
look at the TensorBoard here.
And TensorBoard is going to
show the progress of training.
So let's do that quickly.
I can see similar accuracy and
l curves I can see the graphs.
The graphs are going to
be a little complicated.
OK, the reason why these
graphs are so rich,
with so many computations, is
because I'm using the inception
model, which is large.
And so a lot of the
product, it remains intact,
and only the last few
layers get replaced
with transfer learning.
So by now, my
prediction is done.
It's still running.
Once this prediction is
done, what you want to do
is confusion matrix.
Confusion matrix basically says
what was the intended target
and what is the actual target.
So let's go and look at
the actually pre-run one
so that we can
quickly move forward.
OK, it's still running.
I'll let the predictions go on.
And use the existing one.
OK, I think we are
running out of time,
so I won't go through
all the details of this.
Instead, what I'll do, is I'll
show some existing ones here.
I'll show you the completed
ones while that thing runs.
Same kind of graph,
same sort of the bolts.
And here, instead,
what I've got is
I've got a confusion
matrix, which should come
back there in a few seconds.
And I can see where the
maximum confusion is.
This is the true label, what
it was supposed to predict.
And this is what it
actually predicted.
And mostly, it's all along
a diagonal, which is great.
That's what I want in my model.
I don't want darker
squares anywhere else,
because that is confusion.
And this, and this, these
two are the confusing ones,
because these two are
essentially the same bolts.
One is metric units.
One is imperial units.
Even to an eye, it's
very hard to tell.
The model actually gets it
right in most of the cases,
but there are some angles
at which it may not get it.
All right, so that
concludes my basic bolt one.
The next part that I'm
going to show quickly
is get to an
interesting part, which
is I've got a Raspberry
Pi device on which we've
taken that same model
that we trained,
downloaded it on
the Raspberry Pi.
I'll show it later.
It's taped to the
table right now.
And we're going to run
prediction on that one.
So for that one, I've got the
model already downloaded on it.
I've got this camera here
and a hook, right below here,
and it's going to try
to predict that one.
What I did was, I ran
a few things before,
just to get the environment.
It takes that, and runs
the inference on it.
OK, and now, it's going
to start the inference.
It's running the prediction,
capturing the image,
sending it via wired
network to the Raspberry Pi.
There it is, and
it says a CR hook.
So the first line is
the highest probability.
So obviously talking
[INAUDIBLE] probabilities,
and it says, oh, it's not
likely to be the other things.
It doesn't even
think it's a HFE.
It's 10004.
So that is the correct
inference that I wanted.
So with that, I think
I'll switch over
to my colleague, J.J. And he's
going to show it in our studio.
Thank you.
Second notebook, please.
Second computer.
J.J. ALLAIRE: Hi there, thanks.
Thanks very much.
Today, I want to
briefly show you
some of the work that we've
been doing with both TensorFlow
and Cloud ML and R. So we'll
talk about the TensorFlow R
package.
We'll talk about a new
package, called Cloud ML.
I'll give you a
quick demo that's
doing some prediction
on the census income,
same census income
data set that we
saw before, and talk about what
we're working on next as well.
So first, the
TensorFlow package.
This is an R package that
actually gives access
to the entire TensorFlow API.
The API is mostly
defined in Python.
This R package
actually gives you
access to all the modules,
functions, and classes
that are in the API,
and as a result,
R code looks very similar to
the equivalent Python code.
In this case, you can see the
Hello World is line for line,
almost character for
character, the same.
The TensorFlow R package
works with all versions
of TensorFlow, so
it sort of binds
to whatever version of
TensorFlow is on your machine
and uses that.
A couple of quick examples,
this is the MNIST softmax model
that you see in the
TensorFlow tutorials.
You can see I'm
making some tensors.
I'm creating a session.
I am processing some training
data and making predictions.
The code looks very much like
the equivalent Python code.
Here's a slightly more
sophisticated example
that uses flags, uses some name
scopes, does some summaries,
builds functions, builds
layers using functions.
All again, if you've seen the
tutorials to do this in Python,
works very similar in R. So
that's the TensorFlow package,
and that's kind of
the basis of the work
that we've done with Cloud ML.
So the Cloud ML package,
what is that about?
Our goal with the
Cloud ML package
is to interact with
the Cloud ML service,
typically use the Google
Cloud SDK command line tools.
What we wanted to do is create
very similar to what we just
saw, a local
development workflow
that looks very much like a
standard R local development
workflow, and that with
one gesture, one function
call or one button, you can
take that local work you did
and then train it on Cloud ML.
So over on that source
code, we sort of see
what that looks like.
You work locally
in a file called
train.r that trains
whatever model it
is that you're working on.
You then, when
you're ready to go,
when you think you've
got the model working
the way you want it to, you can
do an emulated local run of it.
You say train local.
It'll do the same thing
that would normally
happen on Cloud ML,
but it'll do it locally
to make sure all the parts
are connected properly.
And then, when you're
ready to work on Cloud ML,
you call train cloud ML.
That's an asynchronous call that
will basically create the job
and give you a handle to it.
And then, when the job is
done, you can collect it.
And as Dinesh said, now you
have that model, you can do it.
You can put it on
a Raspberry Pi.
You can use it locally.
You can put it back up into
Cloud ML for prediction.
It's your model.
And then, we'll also
be adding support
for doing a hyper parameter
tuning in Cloud ML as well.
So let's actually look
at how that works.
The model that I'm
showing here, this
is basically a model
to predict income
from a number of features.
It's using the TFLearn APIs,
defining a bunch of columns,
defining a bunch of layers.
It's creating a
TFLearn estimator.
I'm not going to go into
what all these things are,
but I'm just showing you
sort of the flexibility
that you have in terms
of defining models.
We're going to create some input
functions, all the things you
would normally do to build
a TFLearn stop model.
And then you've got this
file, train.r, which
is where you train the model.
You can build the estimator,
call learn, run, or run,
and it trains.
So I'll just source that,
and it'll start training.
That's, again, a
local training you
want to work on a sample
set of local data,
make sure the model
works the way you
want it to before you
submit it to the cloud.
And we want the
same exact source
code to work locally
and on the cloud.
And to do that, we have this
config file, which basically
says, well, what varies
between local and the cloud,
while the input data, the
training and evaluation data
differs, where you
rate the model differs,
and training parameters
themselves might differ.
So we've got the default
local configuration,
and then, we've got the
Cloud ML configuration.
You can see there, I'm going
to point to some Google Cloud
Storage buckets that might
have much larger data sets.
I'm going to actually put the
job in a Google Cloud Storage
bucket, where I can publish
it for prediction later,
or download it, and
I may change some
of the training parameters.
All right, so it's go back here.
The local training job
completed, and returned an R
list with a bunch of metrics.
So let's see what it would
look like to actually do
that in the cloud.
Same code, I'll
say train cloudml.
And it's going to submit
the job to Cloud ML.
And once that's
submitted, it'll print out
a bunch of information
saying, you know,
here's the URL in
the cloud console
where you can go look at it.
You can see here,
it says OK, if you
want to view the job
online, here's where it is.
Here's where the logs are.
I can check the
status of the job.
And then, ultimately, what I
want to do, is collect the job.
And when I collect the job, it's
actually going to download it.
Right now, the job
is still working,
so it's not going to collect it.
The model will be downloaded
into a local directory, where
I can then do whatever
I want with it.
And in this case,
I'm going to show
some of the things you
might do with that model,
because in the evaluation
phase, you often
want to take the predictions
and either run various automated
diagnostics on them, to
see if they're good enough.
But you also may want to
do some data visualizations
and work with them
interactively.
So here I'm going to
show different ways
to then create predictions out
of the model you've downloaded.
One of them I have here,
I'm going to basically plot
what the predictions were for
occupation based on income
brackets so I can get an
intuitive feel for what kind
of predictions are being made.
Another thing I can do, since
I've got the model local,
is I can build an
interactive tool
for exploring the predictions.
This is a shiny
dashboard, that's
going to basically
take some test data,
and is going to then do local
predictions based on the model
that I've downloaded, and let me
explore the kind of predictions
that are being made.
So this is showing
the various features
for the different levels
of the features, what
was the income prediction.
I can change the
prediction cutoff
and see how that changes
both the overall accuracy
of the model, and
then the confusion
matrix you see in the top right.
So really, the idea here is
that you can work locally in R,
you can do the difficult
heavy lifting of training,
an expensive to train
model, or a model
you want to do hyper-parameter
tuning on in the cloud,
and then you can
bring it back local,
and do all the things you
are accustomed to doing,
when you're doing
modeling with R.
So what are we working on next?
The TensorFlow packets I've
shown, that it's actually
been in development
for about six months,
and that's going to be on
CRAN by the end of this month.
The Cloud ML package
I showed today,
we're working on it in GitHub.
There will be a beta available
by the end of the month.
And then, the TensorFlow
API, as it currently stands,
is really a very close
mapping to the Python API.
And what we really want to
do, for the higher level
TensorFlow APIs that are
coming from TFLearn and Keras
in TensorFlow 1.1, we want to
create fluent, pure functional
R APIs that make it even
easier to use TensorFlow
from within R. So with that,
Hongfei from KPMG will talk.
HONGFEI CAO: All right, thank
you, J.J. Hello, everyone.
This is Hongfei from
[INAUDIBLE] KPMG.
I'm going to introduce,
in a demo, a deep learning
model with beautiful
signature detection,
using Google Cloud ML platform.
Also, showing you how easily you
can deploy our model for future
inferences.
At the end there will be
a [INAUDIBLE] for you.
As Dinesh has
previously presented,
there are four phases a year in
a lifecycle machine learning.
So our business problem is
focused on the challenge
that a financial
service firm have
high volumes of validation.
Their financial
agreement, which is
related to [INAUDIBLE]
or securitization
This validation
has, historically,
been a manual
process, by looking
at the physical documents
and comparing them
with season record.
As you can see, this is
a time consuming process,
and also may lead
to accuracy issues.
Also, it's always hard to
scale on the large data sets.
So by implementing
deep learning and using
TensorFlow and the distributor
in Google Cloud ML platform,
we were able to move
from this manual process,
to an automation that can scan
the entire documents for us,
reduce error, reduce
processing time, eventually.
So in this particular
use case, we're
using the backhaul public image
data for both model training
and testing.
When we design our models,
we actually, or generally,
investigated several options.
The final model is an extension
of a Google [INAUDIBLE].
It accommodates a deep
convolution network,
and an OSTM long-short
term memory [INAUDIBLE].
Other technologies,
such as job [INAUDIBLE]
for regular [INAUDIBLE] and that
of learning, gradient design,
and a loss of function we
use across [INAUDIBLE].
The final part of the
machine learning lifecycle
is the prediction systems.
So basically, we want to
use our training model
for future inferences.
Google Cloud ML platform
offers up capability
that we can deploy our
model on the cloud,
and also manage its own version.
So I will show you
in the details.
Here is an application
engine follow.
As you can see, it is overall,
flow is pretty simplistic.
We [INAUDIBLE] our PDF, and do
image processing through OCR.
We try to assign
attributes with values.
Then we are focused
on this deep learning
model, which is doing the
signature auto detection.
So I'll put away, will
be returned to user,
in the web UI.
Sorry.
Let me show you a scaled down
version of our user interface.
In this upload area, users
can upload the documents
for training and prediction.
So the uploaded document will be
stored a specific cloud folder
within the Cloud Storage.
In the document tab, as you
can see, on the left side
there's a list of documents
that would have been processed.
This particular document,
there are several attributes
extracted for OCR.
And if we scroll down to
the end of the document,
in the last two
pages, as you can see,
there are 1, 2, 3, 4 signatures.
And this another, 100 returned
content, such as Florida,
state name, [INAUDIBLE].
Our prediction result
is showing there
are five signatures, which
there is a false positive, so
Florida, so consider state
name, as well as the signature.
The user can do is speculating
this unconfirmed button,
so we can remove this false
positive from overall result.
Then, in the next model
training iteration,
we can update our model
based on this feedback.
Interesting, is for
this Florida is actually
have a relatively low
confidence, with 79%.
The rest all have
over 90% confidence.
In this desk, we show
you the confusion matrix
for the test data sets.
It can reach 97% recall,
87% precision, and then,
a 0.92 f1 score.
To better visualize our
model using TensorBoard,
it is a very handy tool when you
work on your model, especially.
It is a deep,
complicated network.
You can check your input,
output of tensorship,
as well as network
structure, if it's
a missing an edge,
[INAUDIBLE] edge.
In your model, as you
can see, at the bottom
there is an input node.
As mentioned previously, while
using tobacco public image data
sets, it accommodates
three input
minus the image data itself,
minus a [INAUDIBLE] inbox
when it's available.
Now, we'll fill our input into
this first in, first out queue.
By doing that, when we try
our model on the GPU side,
that it can grab
the image, whenever
needed directly from the queue.
After normalization
and [INAUDIBLE] data,
we train our Google
net architecture.
Expanded, you can see there's
convolution layer, pulling
layer, and a set of
deep convolution layer.
What it does eventually,
is convert our image
into a 1024 dimension
feature space,
while at the same time
preserving low level image
information, such as color
shape, as well as a high level
object information.
In our case, it's a signature.
Through the [INAUDIBLE]
channel and layer channel,
we feed both information into
this so-called decoding phase,
which is OSTM, on [INAUDIBLE].
So output [INAUDIBLE]
outbound inbox
with confidence associated.
Both network will
be trained using
this RMSprop and
adaptive learning
grid and this and optimizer.
Using it, we don't need to
turn our learning range,
and it can give a good
converged performance.
Then after about a
thousand [INAUDIBLE],
we've got our model,
final model built.
So now it's time to
deploy on the cloud.
So first thing is we're going
to save our model on the Google
Cloud Storage, and then in the
web console of the model page,
you can create multiple
versions for one model.
Each version will point
to a certain cloud folder
where your actual
model is stored.
Google allowed us to
create a multiple version.
By doing that, we can serve our
user, the item to query, again,
for them for the full version.
At the same time, we can our
model in different versions.
The switch can be
just in seconds.
Here is some called snippet for
you showing you the Datalab.
So Datalab, as Dinesh
mentioned, is a cloud version
of [INAUDIBLE] notebook.
So using it, we don't get
to set up our local testing
environment.
So first, of course, snippet,
instead of creating a model
on the web console,
you can also create in
from the command line.
Through the G cloud [INAUDIBLE]
engine, model create,
version create.
When you want to submit your
query image for prediction,
you can do two modes.
One is online real time mode,
where the result will be
returned back to your terminal.
Or if you have a satellite
image, a long running job,
you can submit your jobs
through this batch mode.
And the cloud will maintain
and host your job [INAUDIBLE],
so output will be stored
on the cloud storage.
Here is an example the
query we use for prediction.
As you can see,
it's a clean PDF.
At the right bottom corner,
there's a signature,
one signature here.
So the prediction
output for our model
is to look like
something like this.
A set of [INAUDIBLE]
ordered by the confidence.
So we pick it's the best one
with the highest confidence
and mark it as a
green [INAUDIBLE].
The rest of the candidates
is marked as a red one.
So as you can see, the
accuracy is pretty good.
Here is a call snippet
we use to build
the Google net architecture.
We have found residual natch
module and inception module.
For OSTM, we'll be [INAUDIBLE]
using TensorFLow API.
At the end, this is RMSprop.
After a computer
is a [INAUDIBLE],
we use this to apply
our log's function
to minimize this log's function.
So that's all my demo.
Thank you.
With that, hand over
it back to Dinesh.
DINESH KULKARNI: Thank
you, J.J. and Hongfei.
We're almost out of time, but
we are around to take questions.
The KPMG group is
here in the corner.
J.J. is here.
I'll be on this side.
If you have any questions
just see us there.